Beatriz Jacinto tem 17 anos e é a mais
jovem oradora do TEDx@ Youth Leiria.
Integra a equipa como
embaixadora para os jovens.
"Faz acontecer" é o seu lema
e vem pensar sobre o papel dos jovens
enquanto participantes ativos.
Gosta de inverter pensamentos limitados.
(Aplausos)
Muito bom dia a todos.
Se há coisa que aprendi nos meus curtos
17 anos é que nada acontece só a falar
e só a fazer queixas do que está mal
e do que nós não concordamos,
seja, no meu caso, na minha escola
ou seja na minha cidade.
E é disso que vos venho aqui falar hoje.
Eu posso, e é o que vou fazer,
vou falar da minha experiência
enquanto voluntária dentro da minha cidade
e enquanto participante e constituinte
da minha associação de estudantes da Escola
Secundária Francisco Rodrigues Lobo.
Há muita coisa que está por fazer
e eu falo por experiência própria,
daquilo que oiço e daquilo que sei,
que não é muito.
Muitos de vocês sabem mais do que eu
e podem concordar ou não comigo,
mas há muita gente
que diz que tudo está mal,
mas não podemos ficar sentados no sofá
à espera que façam o trabalho por nós.
Porque se há coisa que eu penso
e acredito é que não são os outros
que vão arranjar tudo que está mal
e aquilo que nós achamos que está errado.
É disso que venho falar e mostrar,
e tentar inverter pensamentos,
que é todo o conceito
deste TEDx Youth@ Leiria.
Eu entrei no projeto Geração Mais Leiria,
um projeto de voluntariado da nossa cidade
em que nós podíamos escolher
várias instituições da cidade.
No meu caso escolhi o Espaço Jovem Leiria,
um espaço que costumo frequentar
praticamente todos os dias
e sou muito bem acolhida lá.
O que é que tentei a fazer?
O Espaço Jovem é um sítio
não só de convívio,
onde nós conhecemos muitas pessoas,
mas também um espaço
onde nós podemos estudar.
Como podem ver no Powerpoint,
temos vários espaços:
de estudo, de lazer
e, principalmente de criar amizades
não só com pessoas da nossa idade,
mas sim com a Dona Carla, por exemplo,
que está responsável por todos nós,
quase uma segunda mãe,
é assim que eu a vejo
e é assim que ela é para nós
e é assim que nos trata.
No verão eu fiz voluntariado.
Muita gente não acreditava
no potencial do Espaço Jovem,
achava que não havia muito a fazer.
Foi precisamente por isso que fui para lá,
para inverter o pensamento das pessoas,
para mostrar às pessoas que há muito mais
para além do que se vê, a olho nu.
Acontecem muito mais coisas.
Eu aprendi a estudar com uma profissional
dentro de um espaço
que, para mim, era um espaço de convívio.
Aprendi como é que se trabalha.
Consegui perceber todos os problemas
que acontecem dentro dessa instituição
e todos os imprevistos
que por ali se passa
e de que nós não fazemos
a mais pequena ideia.
Foi muito por isso que eu entrei
e tentar alguma coisa
que achasse que estivesse errado,
ou que estivesse em falta,
neste caso, no Espaço Jovem.
Acho que é muito isso
que nós precisamos de fazer.
Acho que não é
— como eu já tinha referido —
não é a dizer que está mal e ficar sentados
que algo vai mudar.
Podem concordar comigo ou não
mas isso é muito verdade.
No Espaço Jovem
não acontece estudo, convívio,
mas sim apresentações, várias exposições.
Recebemos muitas vezes vereadores da
Câmara, mesmo o presidente da Câmara,
para vários projetos
que o Espaço Jovem envolve e acolhe.
Acho que são coisas muito importantes
que eu estou muito orgulhosa
de ver na minha cidade.
Vejo que estamos a evoluir,
não estamos parados.
Não somos uma cidade
completamente parada
e acho que isso é muito importante.
O meu segundo exemplo
de presença ativa na minha cidade
é ter entrado para a associação
de estudantes da minha escola.
Muita gente, e agora falo
pela parte dos alunos,
queixa-se imenso tanto
da organização da escola,
como da associação de estudantes.
É muito verdade que muitas associações
de estudantes
limitam-se fazer festas
ou coisas do género.
A minha lista, os meus colegas,
e agora a minha família
vamos tentar a inverter todos
esses pensamentos, e todas essas atitudes
que é para isso que nós formámos a lista.
Fizemos tudo isso
para os nossos colegas da escola.
Foi tentar ter uma associação
de estudantes completamente diferente,
completamente dinâmica.
Trazer os nossos amigos,
estudantes e colegas da escola
e perceber que eles têm um sítio
onde ir quando têm dúvidas,
se estiverem sozinhos na escola.
A associação de estudantes
é só mais um aluno,
é um amigo que eles têm.
Nós tentamos englobar
toda a gente num sítio só,
que, neste caso,
é a associação de estudantes.
Nós fizemos uma grande campanha
e a meu ver foi uma campanha
muito inclusiva.
Recolheu um esforço imenso de toda gente,
de todos os nossos colaboradores
e participantes e dos da sede.
Não foi só diversão
porque muita gente pensa
que as listas é tudo só divertir, mas não.
Como podem ver, estivemos
a distribuir "vouchers"
e cupões de desconto aos nossos colegas.
A nossa associação de estudantes
não é só virada para a escola,
o que muitas vezes é.
Nós tentamos incluir toda a gente,
levar a associação para a cidade
e trazer a cidade
para a associação de estudantes
porque acho que uma coisa
não se faz sem a outra.
Nunca pode partir só de nós,
precisamos sempre da ajuda de toda gente.
A nossa associação de estudantes
tem várias premissas
e muitas delas passam
por marcar a diferença
que inclusive era o nosso slogan
e era isso que nós tentávamos mostrar.
Foi mesmo isso a nossa intenção
e acho que isso se aplicou plenamente
ao nosso evento TEDx
em que nós tentamos
trazer novas ideias,
partir de um ponto de partida
e criar novas ideias, criar novas atitudes.
É mesmo por isso que atuamos.
Nós não podemos mesmo ficar quietos.
Acho que isso
é o maior problema do nosso país.
Acho que há muita gente a trabalhar,
claro que sim,
mas também há muita gente
que se queixa e não faz para isso.
Acho que isso é a maior coisa que nós
temos de inverter no nosso país
e começar por um sítio como a nossa cidade,
a nossa escola, a nossa casa por exemplo.
Há sempre qualquer coisa a mudar.
Há sempre qualquer coisa a melhorar.
Acho que temos de fazer acontecer
e não podemos esperar que o façam por nós
e que as coisas aconteçam sozinhas.
Com isto vos deixo
e vos lanço a pergunta:
Estão preparados para inverter atitudes?
Muito obrigada
(Aplausos)